he had been dming me
which is crazy really i feel like you've
been dming a lot of people yeah he would
just kind of communicate
uh and he would send a lot of stuff that
i felt like was kind of wild
like links and things you know like uh
just crazy videos sometimes some of it
was a little bit too it was almost like
why it was like somebody getting hurt or
something you know yeah um
so some of that sometimes i even said
one time i said i don't like that kind
of stuff
um yeah but he seemed like a nice guy i
mean i just messaged with him a few
times
um but this is so sad man hillsborough
county
sheriff uh tampa radios and discuss the
key findings
autopsy that jackson was suffering from
chronic alcoholism man
let me ask you something man because i i
for sure
i deal with my own depression stuff you
know it seems like so much of this like
the more i'm aware of it when i re you
read it you're like this just
all feels like part of mental illness
you know what i mean
yeah and and like um especially for guys
like this
i'm sure it's harder when you've been
such an
alpha masculine dude where your body is
basically the
that when your brain starts to betray
you that you just might
you must not want to admit it you know
what i mean sure it's hard enough like i
i have had a hard enough time and i'm
not some alpha
ultra masculine dude but for these guys
to admit that their brain is betraying
them must be the hardest step for them
you know that's a good point man i
didn't really i hadn't really thought
about that yeah because it's total
opposite of everything of like the
weights
and the ability and the and push through
it yeah that [ __ ] yeah push through it
it's total opposite of everything that
they've heard yeah i can't imagine man
and i think
some of the come down of being like a
hero i mean this guy was a
he was great at football i i i thought
he was still pl i can't
believe he you know i think it had been
five years since he last played which i
found was
kind of amazing but um you know maybe i
wonder if he knew that i
that i had suffered you know with uh
with
drinking or drugs and maybe that's why
he had reached out to someone i don't
know he never said anything like that
yeah
i just found it kind of interesting
maybe he was just a podcast fan you know
i don't know
um but you know i do find that like um
or podcast listeners people
do reach out though you know i talked to
a couple weeks ago or maybe a couple
months ago
on uh fighter in the kid about my
daughter and her being in rehab and all
that stuff
and more people reached out
um and i do find that when when um
and i don't know if it's part of being
in the program or part of being in
recovery
where you know that the more people that
reach out it almost makes that other
person feel better
you know what i mean feeling less alone
i guess oh yeah
and so maybe that's part of the thing
that he you know he understood that
that's where you were coming from too
and
it just made him feel less alone maybe i
don't [ __ ] know
yeah i don't know i wish he'd have led
some since you know i i i don't know i
mean yeah like
i'm sure he was communicating with a lot
of different you know people but he was
just
i don't know it's just sad to think that
a guy was at a
you know that had checked into a hotel
and had been there for almost a month it
seemed like or three weeks
um and that he had by the way if you're
in a hotel for more than two weeks
something's up yeah more than two weeks
yeah
in the same place in bradenton florida
if you're in a hotel for more than two
weeks
i mean look at this guy this dude is a
yeah
physical specimen apparently a really
nice guy i mean
but also how uh the the effect of
alcoholism if you look at it like
he just finished playing five five days
ago
days or five uh five years ago oh yeah
can you put any other information can
you go to another article do you mind
sean
but did they say how he is it say
anything else does it say
how he died let me see one of the jacks
was found dead in a florida hotel room
the 38.
r.i.p vincent jackson man and uh and
just so sorry brother
yeah i mean i just can't imagine him
getting stuck inside of his own head and
thinking he probably couldn't say
anything to anybody
but how fast you have to be drinking for
alcoholism to progress
when you just played football five years
ago i feel like
that's pretty quick yeah because to kill
yourself with alcohol usually takes
quite a long time right hope you enjoyed
that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one